[Music]
this is a haas tl tool room
lathe and today we're going to be
pretending
that it's our very first day with this
lathe and we're going to set up
program and run this part right here
together
in this haas tip of the day
[Music]
so this is our part it's a holder for a
coaxial indicator and it has all these
steps on it so it'll fit into our collet
chuck or our
three jaw without having to change out
our setup or change out those
jaws now i've given mine away and i need
one so this is the part that we're gonna
make
and it'll make a great addition for your
toolbox as well
the through hole on my part is 3 8 inch
diameter because
the shank on my indicator is 3 8 of an
inch
now the shaft on your indicator might be
different
so you'll just use a different size
drill and you might want to adjust the
size of the steps
on the adapter to fit your collets and
that's the beauty of this
you can change everything on this part
you can change the entire
shape and make your own part
we're going to make this part out of
three inch diameter stock
cut to three inches long 76.2
millimeters
we're going to turn the first side and
drill it and that's going to be our
first operation operation 10
then we'll flip the part over turn the
back side up
20 and then we'll take the part over to
our tm
our tool room mill and we drill and tap
it for a set screw
here's the print that we're going to be
using and it describes all of our
lengths and diameters and we can also
use it to describe
how our lathe moves this point here
is 0.5 inches 12.7 millimeters from
zero our center line but we would never
call this point
x point five or x twelve point seven the
tool
at this position is at x one inch
because it creates a one inch diameter
at that position
this is a lathe and all of our x values
are in
diameter now let's take this
over to the lathe on all haas lathes
our z plus is away from the spindle and
our z
minus is towards it x
minus moves are towards our spindle
center line
and x plus moves are away from our
now here are the tools that we will be
mounting in our turret an od
turning tool a spot drill and a drill
when i'm setting off long drills or
reams i may
indicate along the length of a ground
shaft first
making sure that the holder is straight
before fully tightening it down
the lathe needs to know our exact tool
and part locations
and these are our tool offsets and our
work offsets
now to set our tool offsets we will
start by using an
indicator to find the x center of our
drill holders
now once we have found center front to
back
we will highlight the tool offset for
that tool
press the x diameter measure button and
enter
0 for our diameter because we're at x
0. now we'll do this for both of our er
32 drill holders
both tool 2 and tool 3.
we can then load up our stock and
tighten up that chuck
now remember we're kind of pretending
that it's our first day here
and if it really was our first day uh
we'd be telling you to never
ever walk away
with your t-handle left in the chuck
really bad idea
it's not safe and everybody in the shop
will make fun of you
on to our turning tool now to set the x
tool offset for our turning tool we will
skim the outside diameter of our part
jog straight away in the z positive
direction
and then measure our part diameter with
our tool offset highlighted
we will press x diameter measure and
enter the diameter value we just
measured
to set the z tool offset for our turning
tool
we will skim the z face of our part and
then move straight away in the x
axis with our tool offset still
highlighted
we will press the z face measure button
we now have a
clean z face to set all of our tool z
offsets up against we will jog our drill
up to the face of our part
as we slide a shim or a paper between
the two
continuing to slowly jog the tool
towards the face
until the shim drags with the tool
offset
highlighted for that drill we're going
to press the z
face measure button and that's it we've
set the tool
length offs at the z for tool two
we can also subtract the thickness of
any shim that we might have used
we'll repeat this process for tool three
our other drill
for this first operation we're going to
be using work offset
g54 so we're going to go to the work
offset page
and we're going to make sure that both
our x and our z values
are set to zero on this part
we have to tell the machine where our
part is and that is our work offset
the face of the part and the spindle
center line
are our x and our z zeros that's where
we touched off our tools
and that's what we told the machine now
if it seems like we covered
all of that far too quickly for such an
important part
of our setup we agree that's why we made
a complete video
on how to manually set our tool and work
offsets and we will link to that video
in the description with our tools and
our work offsets
set we can move on to the heart of this
video which is programming our part
at the control to write our program
we'll need some numbers from our print
we'll consolidate all of our x and z
locations
to make things easier to read and now
our x
z values are looking like something we
can enter right into the control to
create a
program we will add in some
lead in and lead out lines to our
profile to account for our raw stock
and we'll decide where we want our rough
turning operation
to start this is the information that
we'll need
to program this first operation you
don't know it yet but we just programmed
our
our first part kind of so close
now now this is a tl lathe which means
it
comes standard with vps our visual
programming system and that is what
we'll be using we look at the pictures
answer some questions and the control
creates the code
now for for a really simple part where
we're just
turning the outside of some stock or
we're just facing it
we can go to the templates that od turn
or or face for a more complex part
with all kinds of steps and chamfers and
radius
we will define our profile in shape
creator
so edit shape creator
and origin for a new shape and once our
profile is fully defined
we will open up that profile back in our
vps template
to apply some tool paths let's walk
through these questions together
our raw dimensions define where our raw
stock will start
and if we look in the lower corner we
will find expanded instructions for
every
line to help us out we'll enter x 3.0
and z 0.05 our stock is now defined
showing up on our screen as this green
box
now our rapid point is where our turning
tool will wrap it to
before it starts feeding into the part
now this point is incredibly important
it defines
where our od roughing starts everything
below
and to the left gets machined and every
move
above and to the right of this point are
rapids
now we are going to set our rapid point
just outside of our stock
set it too high and we waste time
cutting air
and if we were to set it too low then
our tool will try and remove too much
material
on those first passes we're going to
enter x
3.1 and z 0.1
now something cool happened when we
entered these values
the control automatically filled in our
z start position for us
now that is our contour start position
now this is one of the most important
lathe tips that i can give you whether
you are using dps
or programming by hand if you are
getting
alarms when using a roughing cycle
look right there look at your rapid
point and look at your
profile start position and make sure
that they share the same z value
position
now that was kind of a long explanation
but we don't want you frustrated we want
you making parts
which is why we automatically filled in
that start z position
uh don't overwrite it just leave that
one where it needs to be
for our x value we will enter
minus .062 oh wait a second
where did this number come from i
apologize let me
explain our turning tool has a radius on
the tip of it
31 thousandths of an inch in this case
about 0.8 millimeters
to clean up the face completely we need
to move the insert below
center line by the insert radius amount
and because all of our x values are in
diameter
we must go to x minus 62 thou
and not just x minus 0.031
no matter what size your tool nose
radius is
we need to account for it for the same
program and metric
we would program it to x minus 1.6
to account for a 0.8 millimeter radius
on our insert
now if we program this particular
turning tool to x 0
we would end up with a nib or a pip on
our part
and it wouldn't fully clean up which
would cause a drill to walk
or it would just leave a pip this is one
reason we should know exactly what
insert radius we are using before we
even start programming
now from here on we're going to start
entering in those xz locations from our
print
adding rows for each new line segment
this start x and z position is the first
point of our
contour x minus
z 0.062 1 the start of our lead in
to create the second point in our
contour
we will add a new row
and select linear feed motion
x minus 0.062
z zero it filled in the angle for us
automatically here
we will leave chamfer and round
at zero because we don't need any
chamfer or fill it
at this intersection we'll add another
row
now our third point lands at x
1.0
and z zero and we do want a chamfer at
this corner so we'll enter
0.02 under chamfer that's our chamfer
size
we'll add another row the next point
entering x1 z minus 0.285
no chamfer here new row
and we will work our way through our
contour entering each
xz point as a new row a new position
in shape creator that is it our last
line segment our lead
out and we are done now we can always go
back in
and adjust those end points or add line
segments if we need to
and we can also add in chamfers or
radiuses
in fact that's the way i usually use my
shape creator
i plot all of my endpoints and then i go
in and i add in my chamfers or my
radiuses just because i like
i like seeing how those things change
graphically
a press of the f4 key and we will name
and save this
shape with our shape all saved we can
import that into a vps template
and add our tool pass i'll press home
and then use the cursor keys to navigate
up and over to our vps od roughing cycle
now this template is good for od
roughing
and finishing and the first question
that's going to ask
it's going to ask for a shape and it
says press enter
to select your predefined shape file
and how convenient we've got one all
ready for the task
it defaults to the active tool and the
turret but we can change that if we
would like
now if the tool we have chosen still has
an offset of zero
the template is going to warn us to go
set our tool offset
no tool offset present please set tool
offset to continue
nothing good can happen if we forget to
set our tool offset
and the control is trying to save us
from ourselves
now we have chosen a legitimate turning
tool and offset number
and we'll go ahead and use work offset
g54
for this first operation for our max rpm
we're going to set that to
1000 now this tl lathe all tlas can go
much faster than that
but this might be your first part our
first part so we'll leave it at 1000.
next we have our surface speed and for
that information we're going to go to
the products page for the inserts that
we're using
these charts give us a reasonable
starting depth of cut
feed rate and surface speed now we'll
enter 1601
now that'll give us a really high rpm
but we will never
get there because of the max rpm value
that we just set for safety more feed
and speed videos to come
flood coolant yes please stock diameter
3 inches and the control got that from
our from our shape creator file already
for us
nice stock removal cycle we will choose
71 for
od roughing tool nose comp
we will just leave this on great topic
but for another video
doc depth of cut will set to .055 inches
or 1.5 millimeters
and we got that information from our
feed and speed chart
and x finish stock z finish stock we're
gonna leave those
at ten thousand three thousand that's
the allowance that we're leaving for our
finish pass
feed rate we're going to set this to
0.016
16 000 of an inch per revolution and we
might have to come back to this value
and bump it up a little bit i might go
to 0.02
to break up those long stringy chips xz
rapid points those
also came in with our shape creator file
we already filled in that information
and retract home both x and z
my template already defaults to no for
retract home
x and z and you will want to make sure
you answer no to these questions as well
now this is a tl and we are running very
long tools so we do not want to send the
turret
all the way to the home position before
changing tools those long tools could
hit something
when n no is selected it'll ask us to
enter a tool change position
tool change positions x and z now we'll
choose a spot
a reasonable distance in front of our
part to do our tool change
uh we'll choose x 3.1
and z eight inches z eight inches in
front of our part
should be safe because our longest tool
is about five inches
we will talk more about safe tool
positions in a moment
end m code we're going to leave this as
a
one that's going to put an m1 at the
bottom of the program that we're going
to be exporting
that's called an optional stop we're
going to talk more about that in a
minute
when we run the part had we entered 30
it would put an m30
at the end of our code which tells the
control that the program is
done and it rewinds the program to the
beginning
but we're not done we're going to be
adding more drilling and turning
so for now m1 is just fine
we are done that was our last question
and
our options at this point are written in
this top right hand corner
we could just close the doors right now
and press the cycle start button
and it would run that first operation
but but that's not our complete program
we have
some more operations we'd like to add so
we're not going to press cycle start
plus we want to verify things we're
going to press the f4
generate gcode button and then select
three
create new program we're going to place
this new program in memory which is just
the main folder on the control
and we're going to fill in the blanks
it's going to ask for an o number a file
name and a comment
coax 10
and coax opt 10 and press
enter our new program will show up
when we press the list program key we
can select it
and if we want to we can run it in
graphics
and that is it that is our part it's
running right now
kind of in graphics world now before we
run
a real part in the machine with real
cutting tools we want to add in our
finish cycle
and those drilling operations for our
finishing cycle we're going to go right
back into
our vps template pressing the edit key
now we're going to go up to our stock
removal cycle
except this time we're not going to
choose 71 for roughing
we're going to choose zero for finish
the question's changed a little bit and
we're going to enter a new
lower feed rate for this finished cycle
and generate that code i'll press f4
except this time instead of creating a
new program because we already have a
program
we're going to press 1 and insert to
clipboard
now what just happened there was kind of
like what happens when you press ctrl c
copy on your computer it copied it to
the clipboard and it automatically
opened up
our program in the editor now we just
have to decide where that
new finish pass is going to go and we
want that after the current roughing
operation
at the end of our program so we'll press
end
and that takes us all the way to the
bottom it's on our clipboard we'll go to
the editor here and press
f1 that brings us to our menu i'll arrow
over to
paste from clipboard select that
and it did it it added our new finish
pass to the bottom
of our original program our 4321 program
we'll repeat that exact same process for
our drilling cycles
again we're going to get our feed rate
from the manufacturer
and we want to be careful here with our
retract x xhome and our retract
z home we're going to want to answer
this question with a big
no we do not want the tools to go home
before doing a tool change so we're
going to say no
and again we're going to set our tool
change position z way out there
eight inches in front of our part a nice
safe position
we're going to f4 generate code send
this to the clipboard
and add these operations to the bottom
of our main program
that is it we'll run it in graphics here
this whole program written at the
control using dps and shape creator
now while this is not a video on hand
programming there are some codes that
every lathe machinist needs to know and
understand
we've written these down in an essential
nine lines document that we'll link to
before ever programming or setting up a
job
we should be looking through the manual
and making sure that we understand these
basic codes and beyond this we can look
at that nine lines document
and see what codes we need to be working
on next
back to graphics and what we are really
looking for here
are rapid lines that are that are
running right through our part
we're off in weird directions if you see
something like that
we should stop single block through our
program
until we find the problem and correct it
before we run this program for real
we're going to go into the program and
just give our our tool offsets and our t
numbers
one final look we're going to make sure
we didn't make any mistakes
so in memory i'll press t down arrow
t 101 101 is my turning tool
it is my turning tool t down arrow again
there's my finish pass t101 that's good
t down arrow t202 is my center drill my
spot drill
and that is in fact where i've put it in
the turret
and finally t303
is my long drill everything matches up
well we've got our program our tools are
all set we know they match our program
but as your friend as someone who really
wants to see you succeed
we've got to talk about collision
avoidance
a good setup person will make sure that
our tools don't bump
into anything and these kind of
accidents
are prone to happen they're common in a
few key places
number one during a tool change number
two
when this turret when your tools are way
back
at the home position whether it's back
towards the tail stock or towards the
door
and number three when our turning tool
is getting really close
to these jaws we are running longer
drills so we do
not want to command a tool change when
this turret is anywhere near
the chuck our tail stock
or even these doors we also have to make
sure
that when our turning tool is at its
furthest z-minus
position when it's actually cutting the
part that there are no
other tools in our turret that can hit
these chuck jaws
when our turning tool is at its furthest
z-minus position
and we know from from our program our
blueprint and running thing in graphics
that on this particular program we're
going to be going as far as
z minus 2.1 inches we can
jog over two inches to the left of our
face
and we can see that there's nothing here
to hit this
jaw but if we had a fourth tool in this
turret
say a ream for a more precise center
hole
you would really want to place those
things carefully so
nothing could hit those jaws check that
out
verify nothing's going to hit before you
run your part
okay so all of our checks are done
okay all of our checks are double done
we can now press the five percent rapid
button on the control
we're going to press the single block
button which will
allow just one line of code to be run
with each
push of the cycle start button we're
going to close these doors
and we'll start running this part we're
going to push the cycle start button
over and over and over again we're going
to watch our tool our turning tool
move closer and closer to the part
slowly and when it's about that far away
about an inch away from the part 25
millimeters away
we're going to press feed hold and stop
we'll then go to the control and look at
our position distance to go
values the distance to go value is how
far the machine is going to move
if you press that cycle start button one
more time so if it says distance to go
minus 5 inches but we are only this far
away from the part
stop it something terrible is going to
happen because if it moved five inches
we would
we would have a problem something's gone
wrong we need to stop
we need to check our program check our
offsets and correct the issue before we
proceed
but in this case we've stopped that far
in front of our part
our numbers look reasonable so we'll
continue
we'll single block through the first few
passes of this
roughing cycle then we can probably turn
single block off
the cycle looks safe we might turn on
option stop we talked about this before
the option stop button
that's going to cause the machine to
stop every time there's an
m01 in the program and
bps added that for us after each and
every operation
and that's the perfect time to check our
coolant make sure everything's got
coolant on it
and make sure there aren't chips wrapped
around tools
and because we're saying this might be
our first day
you never reach into a machine and
remove long stringy chips
with your bare hands they can cut like
razor wire
[Music]
now with this first operation done we're
going to flip it over
and repeat this entire process on the
second side of the part
creating a program double checking our
tool change positions
and for this second operation we will
choose and use
g55 in our templates now running a
second operation
g55 is explained in the linked lathe
offset video that we referred to
[Music]
to finish up this part we're going to
take it over to the tm
mill and we'll drill and tap it for a
set screw
that was our tl part walkthrough i hope
you feel a bit more familiar
with this versatile machine now i
really like the ability to program a
part like this right at the control
but for a lot of parts there is simply
no replacement
for a modern cam system we want you to
be successful and this means
becoming confident not only with your
machine
but with your cam system no matter how
we programmed our part
it's always a good idea to go back into
our proof program
and say so and if you are running a
proof program
then run it at a hundred percent rapid
this is a precision machine
and if it ran fine the first time it's
going to go the exact same spot
every time after that so let it fly
when you first start up a tl lathe you
will in many cases
see a zero return menu like this one it
gives us
an option to hand jog to a safe position
first
before we zero return our tool turret
which
will command a tool change automatically
and then
we can safely zero return our x and z
axes
if your tl or any haas mill
or lathe really does not have that zero
return
pop-up menu we can still safely start
things in order
if we use the zero return single
function instead of the power up key
if we need to jog this turret out of the
way before the machine's been
honed we can turn on setting 53
jog without zero return this allows us
to jog
to that safe tool change position it is
a good time to mention our bonus content
and if you follow this link right here
and it's also in the description it'll
take you to the bonus content
page for all of our videos where we'll
have the blueprints that we use
all throughout this video we'll also
link to our
essential nine lines video with all
those codes needed for the lathe
and we'll also link to our lathe offset
video which really is essential
viewing when setting up one of these
lathes
well that is it for this time thank you
for letting us be a part of your success
and for watching this haas tool room
lathe tip of the day
you